MICHAELA KERRISSEY: Every
day in organizations
all around the globe, impromptu
teams are formed that must flexibly
collaborate regardless of
shift changes, emergency
situations, siloed specialties,
or cross-sector partnerships.
AMY C. EDMONDSON: We call this
dynamic form of collaboration teaming.
Teaming is a requirement
for delivering optimal care.
Yet, it doesn't
necessarily come naturally.
MICHAELA KERRISSEY: Professionals in the
health care and life science industries
know that their work is a team sport.
What they may not know is
that the science of teaming
can help them thrive.
DONALD M. BERWICK: I discovered that
outside health care had developed
a whole bunch of sciences that
supported continual improvement
and breakthroughs that health
care just had never learned.
MAYA RUPERT: Being a leader does not
mean being a subject matter expert.
Your job is to see the whole board.
Everybody else gets to go
deep, and you need to go broad.
MICHAELA KERRISSEY: By learning from
experts in health care and business,
you will understand how
you and your colleagues
can create and implement a process
of teaming within your organization.
TOMISLAV MIHALJEVIC: Teamwork is not
some kind of a corporate catchphrase.
Teamwork in what we do translates
into improvement of human lives.
AMY C. EDMONDSON: By
the end of the course,
you'll appreciate what enables effective
teamwork and why teamwork can fail.
You'll be able to articulate the
importance of psychological safety
and a joint problem solving
orientation and rethink
the role of a leader and the
organization in the context of teaming.
MICHAELA KERRISSEY: Don't
leave teaming up to chance.
Draw on the science.